[Music]
it is the new
year and I'm bringing in one of the men
who's helped transform my life
personally to give us some insights
what's up brother
s John how you doing what are you
doing oh I'm just uh you know working
being a dad not sleeping because I got
little ones but every other than that
just having a good time man listen if I
was to um be honest about your Instagram
feeds recently it sounds like you're
tired because y'all were blowing up Cabo
for the last however many days oh that's
no you know we went down there uh to
meet with Dr Khan uh for some treatments
and stuff that we'll be talking about on
the show um and you know to primarily we
want to see if it helps with Adam's
psoriasis that he' been struggling with
but yeah I mean it was it was gorgeous
down there so it was pretty cool was
were um did did y'all walk away with any
um insights into oh man we're on to
something here
you know um it's a bit controversial but
uh stem cell infusions seem to have some
pretty profound effects on autoimmune
type issues um so yeah that and and
we're just going to be very honest about
how it works or doesn't work Dr Khan
knows this he's very confident we trust
him so we'll you know we'll keep you
posted that's so cool well to everybody
listening this is my good buddy s to
Stefano um an integral part A
Cornerstone part of the Mind pump gang
um out of San Jose California who have
been instrumental in changing my
personal fitness um s in particular
behind closed doors has really helped me
work through some disordered eating
challenges I've had my whole life and
I'm somebody that I regularly go to and
say man I need some help and so uh
luckily for me I've got a cell number
you guys don't but here's why I'm
bringing cell on today this show is
going to roll is rolling out into the
New Year we're about two or three weeks
into the new year and this is when
everybody starts falling apart they've
made all these announcements to the
world about what they're going to do
with their health with their Fitness
with their
nutrition and about week three they're
like this sucks I'm out and S you worked
in um gyms forever right as a personal
trainer you you ran gyms this is about
week three into four five and six when
the gym goes from being super pack to
there's just back to the same old gang
right yeah it uh the the traffic and the
revenue of gyms goes up a good 50% % and
that stays High through February by
March it starts to dip back down and you
lose most people that that came in that
initial wave and it's just very very
very predictable very consistent the
fitness industry and the gyms know this
they capitalize on it uh but the fail
rate is it's just it's so high and uh
this was you know one of the reasons why
I left jyms to be quite honest yeah what
what is it about the business model that
they this isn't aide this not even why I
called you but it's an interesting
thread I want to pull real quick why
would a
business
um why would somebody open a business
without the out the the in result being
helping a customer it it feels very much
like Blockbuster where the bulk of their
revenue came when their customer failed
when their customer didn't bring back
the movie that's when Blockbuster made
their money and ultimately that always
fails business-wise long term John
you're hitting nerve with me this is why
we started the podcast this is why I
left uh the gym industry a lot of
markets uh well markets are good at
giving us what we want but they're
terrible at giving us what we need and
the fitness industry is just like any
other market and so what they figured
was people want to have access to the
gym and they'll keep paying if it's
cheap enough and they won't show up and
so jyms with that model they're like
look the heavy users the people that pay
us 20 bucks a month and use the gym
consistently they cost us money we lose
money on them they wear down the
equipment they're in here all the time
the people that pay us and don't show up
that's pure profit I mean if everybody
showed up that had a gym membership on a
consistent basis gyms would have to shut
down they they would exceed the
regulations for how many people can
allow in the building that's the truth
wow and the whole industry is is built
on that and uh I just couldn't live with
that you know it was just it just didn't
didn't work for me um and as a trainer
you know I was like I really really
wanted people not just to get results
but then to be able to keep them that's
the hard part like how can we get people
to to stay consistent and make this a
part of their life not just do it for
two or three months when they're feeling
motivated or maybe feeling bad about
themselves um and that's again that's
why we start the podcast but yeah that's
that's what happens in the gyms and it's
very very clear why this happens um and
we really try to communicate this on the
show as much as possible well just I
mean you know this as well as I do the
Arc of any business that ultimately does
not result in life change or solving a
problem for a
customer will end period yes and it just
depends on how long they can squeeze it
out but eventually it goes away and I
don't know if it's some of the
incredible home gym equipment that you
and I both have I mean I I don't know
what ultimately turns turns it over um
or if it's an economic but who knows
what it is but we all know that if
you're not solving a problem for
customer Downstream your business goes
away but that that's a secondary thing
all right so here we are it's I'm
recording this show right before
Christmas it's coming out for people who
are 3 weeks into the new
year I'm going to ask you give me some
bite-size tips for John delon's fitness
goals in 24 that people can use they're
three weeks in they're like I'm going to
lose 50 pounds in the first month and
they're already like that's not going to
happen or I'm never eating a carb again
or whatever crazy thing they came up
with this is going to allow them before
January is over to control all delete
and actually do something that's going
to become like you said I love it a part
of your life this is a way of being
moving forward so give me some headlines
here that I can incorporate as I build
my fitness goals for 2024 oh than I love
that you asked this question John by the
way one thing I love about Fitness so
much is it's an example of like life
okay so this time I sound a little
esoteric but it's really true so what
I'm about to say I think is going to
resonate right when we're in a hyper
motivated state of mind and that
motivation may come from uh self-hate or
guilt or oh my God the holidays I feel
so terrible or I just totally indulged
or it's a new year so now it's going to
be a new meat whatever when we're in
that motivated state of mind without
realizing we assume that that motivated
State of Mind is how we're always going
to feel so we end up making promises
with ourselves or with other people uh
we end up setting goals for ourselves
assuming that this is how we're always
going to feel and so what it looks like
is uh I never exercise and I've been
eating whatever I want to now I'm going
to go to the gym and I'm going to show
up four days a week for sure and I'm
never going to eat a carb or I'm going
to completely overhaul my diet and
completely overhaul my life and that's
works as long as you're in that hyper
motivated state of mind which 100% will
go away nobody ever stays I've never had
to convince a client to work out or eat
right when they felt that way that's
easy the hard part is when that feeling
goes away because it will because life
is not about feeling the same all the
time so the key here is making promises
with yourself and imagining yourself in
the other states of mind the normal
states of mind the unmotivated states of
mind when I'm tired when I'm busy when I
don't want to all right what does that
look like so what that typically looks
like is a really small step and by the
way there's no there's no wrong answer
here so you have to have this
conversation with yourself so like to
give you an example I had a a client
once I trained I use her as an example
all the time and hopefully she doesn't
hear these because I hope I don't make
her feel bad but it turned out to be it
turned out to be a real incredible
success story but she had such such a
terrible diet such a bad relationship
with food and she came to me in this
motivated state of mind you know this is
what I'm going to do and I we sat down I
said look I said you you want to go from
here to here and in my experience this
is going to fail because it's too big of
a jump how do you normally feel let's
take some steps that you think you'll be
able to stick to for the rest of your
life let's use that as the context and
so this is what we started with you
ready she started with I'm going to
drink an extra glass of water every day
and I'm going to walk for 10 minutes
three days a week that's where she
started okay but she started there
because she was able to put herself in
that state of mind of okay I know how I
can feel I know how hard this will be
for me so let me give I can start with
this promise and I think it can be
consistent with that now here's what
happened she followed that and
eventually it became a part of her life
and then she asked her that qu herself
that question again what's another step
I can take and over time the space
between these steps gets smaller and the
steps become larger because you start to
develop this skill of discipline that's
you you constantly hear Fitness
professionals talk about you start to
develop the skill of you know how I can
make changes that will stick but you
have to start there don't make yourself
promises or make these big jumps because
this is how you feel now and without
realizing it you're assuming you're
always going to feel that way because
you're guaranteed to fail you're you're
you're writing checks you can't cash
when that feeling goes away you let
yourself down and if you do that enough
times and this is what the fitness
industry has done so terribly is that
we've let we've capitalized on those
motivated state of Minds by selling
people everything and you know and
throwing everything but at them but the
kitchen sink and once they fail three or
four times they never come back and
that's uh that's terrible absolutely
terrible so there really is no no right
answer with the first step it's got to
be the one that you think you can
maintain for the rest of your life
knowing how you can feel when you're not
feeling as motivated as you may be right
now at the beginning of the year man so
I'm thinking back to 2015 for me uh and
I I've been an athlete most of my life
but I and then I start I was an academic
nerd for a while so I spent less time in
the gym 2015 I think was
when um I just made a deal with myself
you're gon to you go a home gym I got a
squat rack at my house and a few weights
you're going to do you're going to do
four times uh four times a week just
something
something and here it is um getting up
knocking on the door of 10 years
later and I've got a pretty elaborate
routine but I think it worked exactly as
you said but here's I fall prey to it so
I I'm living that out in my life over a
decade it's a part of my life now in a
way that's like if I don't hug my
daughter on a regular day my day feels
off similarly if I don't exercise my day
feels off and three weeks ago I was like
dude you're going to do 60 pounds in
your ruck every single day on a
treadmill at this incline for 30
straight days and here's what happened I
got stuck in a cell phone store for 4
hours the other night because cuz they
they moved one set of data to one phone
blah and dude I got home at 11:00 at
night and I felt like such a sh like a a
a a shameful loser you you failed what a
loser what a and that's my self talk
dude right now 23 so dumb I I fell for
it again I fell for it again I fell for
it again and you nailed it it's so easy
you go to the gym and some Beefcake
McGee and two tight of a shirt is like
what are your goals and you're like I
want to get an ABS he's like sweet and
then the first workout the next day you
can't wipe properly because your hands
don't work and your abs hurt so bad and
you can't get off the toilet and then
you can't go the next day or I'm doing
like make up some workout that's like
you got to do everything every so what
you're saying is all right we've looked
across the landscape that crap just
doesn't
work can you make some small changes on
a regular
basis whenever it has to be let me
hammer this home okay not only Will you
fail but that's also not how the body
adapts any way okay when you're trying
to get leaner build muscle get stronger
improve your Mobility come healthier
right those are all
adaptations that your body is moving
towards as a result of some kind of a
signal that you sent your body and that
signal is perceived as some sort of a
stress right so if I exercise it's a
little bit of stress on my body in fact
if you were to take my my blood markers
post exercise it would look like oh my
God what's going on inflammatory markers
are up and what's happening this person
so what your body does just like
developing calluses on your skin or or
you know tanning because you're out in
the sun your body adapts to that stress
so that it no longer becomes a stress
right and so then what happens is you're
more fit so you got to work out a little
harder or do a little longer or whatever
in order to continue to induce those
changes okay so where am I going with
this look if you're listening right now
and your activity looks like nothing and
your diet is you know you you've accept
it like it's not very good you don't
need if if you take too big of a step
you're going to overwhelm your body's
ability to adapt to those stresses it's
no different than if I lived in my
mother's basement for 10 years and then
I go out to the hot baking you know
California Sun and try to accomplish a
you know Mediterranean can in one day I
would just burn myself that's all I
would just damage my body and I wouldn't
get a tan right so so regardless of
where you stand with this not only will
you that the data will show if you if
you take two bigest steps you're G to
fail anyway because you'll stop but even
if you think to yourself like no I'll
keep doing this your body doesn't adapt
that way anyway you're going to overcome
your body's ability to adapt to the
stress you're not going to get stronger
you're not going to get more fit you're
you're going to overwhelm your body
you're going to become more tired
overtrained stress hormones are going to
go out of whack you're not going to feel
very good and like you said people think
that feeling like they you know like I
can't wipe myself the next day means I
had a good workout no that means you did
too much that means you got to sunburn
you're not going to get that tan so
wherever you're at the appropriate step
is not only the one that you're most
likely to stick to it's also the one
that's going to get you there the
fastest so I want people to understand
that and have to sell this constantly to
people because they think that they're
trading you know uh that the trade is
I'm going to get there slower but I'm
more likely to stick to to the goal no
no no it's not one is fast one is slow
it's one is yes one is no that's the
fact so the right way is the right way
is the right way and again I hope I'm
selling effectively because I want
people to understand this if you do this
the way that I'm expressing it and
explaining it it's going to work or at
least it's far more likely to work there
is no other way so I also love so good
man I I I love this because challenge
looks different for everybody and here's
what I mean um for some people going for
a walk three days a week for 10 minutes
is a dramatic change in your life
correct and having an extra glass of
water instead of a Diet Coke is a
dramatic change and for me
I lift weights all the time you know
what I have to do when I was doing MMA
regularly I used to be able to stand up
and pick up my leg and put my foot my
heel on somebody's shoulder I can't
touch my toes anymore so this year for
me I'm getting incorporate not I'm GNA
be able to do the splits but I'm not
doing that because normally that would
be me but based on this one phone call S
I'm going to incorporate one day a week
I feel so good when I lift I'm GNA do
one day of Mobility a week I'm GNA try
that and I bet over time my hips will
loosen up my knees and shoulders loosen
up and I'm going to feel so good that
I'll make it a regular part of my life
100% 100% it's it is a relationship look
if you if if if someone's listening you
know and you too John and even to myself
right plan on doing this for the rest of
my life I don't plan on stopping right
so it's a relationship that you have
with this activity or with these pursuit
of you know improving my health my
Vitality consider this let's let's let's
forget the fact that we want to look
ripped or we want to appear a particular
way or we we have you know body image
issues all of us are challenged with
those myself included consider this a
more fit healthy version of you is just
going to enjoy life more okay period end
story right and so what that means is
your use your workouts and use your diet
to improve the quality of life
regardless of the context of your life
now what that means is your workouts and
your diet are going to shift in change
just like your life does you know so
sometimes John you're going to go to the
gym and or you're going to go to your
garage and you're going to work out hard
because you got good sleep everything's
going good in your life and you feel
great sometimes you're G to be really
stressed out maybe you got bad sleep
maybe something's happening with your
kids or whatever and your Your Capacity
is much lower you don't go in the garage
and beat yourself up that's not going to
improve the quality of your life now you
go in the garage and now I'm relieving
stress maybe I'm stretching maybe I got
to take a day off even right so when you
look at it that way way you tend to
train yourself and eat in a way that's
appropriate to the context of your life
and then what happens you develop this
it's like you got this Swiss army knife
where you could pull out the right blade
for whatever's happening in your life
you're like I'm tired oh here's I'm
gonna work out because I'm tired or
here's I'm not gonna work out because
I'm tired or my digestion is off this is
what my diet's going to look like as a
result or man everything's firing in all
cylinders I feel amazing I think I'm
gonna I'm G to train for a PR in my
deadlift or I'm going to see how how
fast I can run the mile or whatever but
when you do with that you develop this
relation ship with this Pursuit um and
it it won't serve you wrong if you do it
that way you'll you you you're going to
steer yourself more towards an
appropriate application of these things
because the challenge is that that
people always run into is they're just
they're they're applying it
inappropriately to themselves in a way
where it's not sustainable or it's not
giving them the the the payback that
they expect or their expectations are
narrowly focused on just the scale and
they're not observing the full breadth
of what becoming more fit and healthy
can do for you or I think the a last one
is one that man you you personally have
really helped me with is you look so
gross toone you have to beat yourself up
because this is what you get this is
what you deserve for looking like this
and if you exercise and you don't just
beat yourself up well now you're even gr
you're grosser in your character on top
of not looking right and so all dude
thank you so much we're we're going to
link to if everybody listening I talk
about this all the time but um the maps
program mind pump are they're the ogs in
the space for if you want a particular
workout to follow to take all the guest
workout you can peace meal stuff
together by Googling everything under
the sun and if you're like me you've
probably spent more time trying to
Google and peace meal a workout together
than actually just going to the gym and
doing what you need to do um um s and
his team have taken all the guest
workout they've got the best programs on
the planet and I know that because I use
them in my house uh multiple programs
and uh once I get this this nagging
shoulder injury taken care of dude I
can't wait to get on Old Man's strength
man it's going to be an awesome I can't
wait can't wait um but s thank you and
your gang um Adam and Justin and Doug
that the whole team for putting out such
extraordinary stuff and for finally dude
telling the truth about all this thank
you so much you got it my brother all
right take care hey everybody um we'll
link to mind pump and all the workouts
in the show
notes